now you'll learn how to run queries to
find conferences that were created by
specific user remember that each
conference has an ancestor and that the
ancestor is a profile entity of the user
who created it here's how you create a
query to get all the entities that have
a particular ancestor you just add the
ancestor function to the end of the
query creation and you need to specify
the key of the parent that is the key of
the ancestor whose descendants you want
to query for this kind of query is
called an ancestor query but you could
also think of it as a descendant query
that's because it gets all the
descendants of a particular entity so if
conferences for example you can get all
the conference's that were created by a
certain user so go ahead and add a new
function in conference a P called get
conferences created that returns
conferences created by the logged in
user so again the HTTP method is going
to be post and this time the user must
be logged in because you're trying to
get the conference is created by the
logged in user and define the function
to return all the conference's that the
user created and again test on localhost
before you deploy to App spot and run
your query on localhost first because if
you deploy direct to appspot the first
and then try to run the query for the
first time you're going to find it
doesn't work so after you've defined and
tested you'll get conferences created
method take a look at the code and come
and answer this quiz what I want you to
do is figure out which is the right code
here to complete this statement to get
all the conference's created by the user